REELS:
On March 10, 2023, Meta announced that they
would no longer be offering bonuses to Reels
creators on Instagram or Facebook.
This was a massive surprise given that everyone
else was doubling down on short form content
in order to compete against TikTok.
But, Zuckerberg had chosen to go against the
grain and pull back on short form content.
Why?
Well, promoting reels was actually losing
Meta quite a bit of revenue.
It turns out that people scrolling through
Reels is a lot less profitable than people
scrolling through the Instagram feed, $500
million less per quarter or $2 billion less
per year to be precise.
Hearing this, you’re probably inclined to
think that Reels were taking a massive toll
on Instagram’s top line and that’s why
decided to pull back.
After all, if this was WhatsApp, that $2 billion
toll would be twice their total annual revenue,
but the same cannot be said about Instagram.
In fact, it’s actually the exact opposite
with Instagram.
In 2023, Instagram is expected to pull in
just over $50 billion in revenue.
Let me put that in perspective.
That’s $20 billion more than YouTube, $37
billion more than TikTok, and over 11 times
more than Snapchat.
In fact, Instagram is the second most lucrative
social media platform in the world only beaten
out by Facebook themselves.
So, out of all the players that are pursuing
short form content, Instagram is actually
the most well off, and that $2 billion toll
only translates to 4% of their annual revenue.
So, Zuckerberg’s decision to pull back from
shorts is less of a financial move and more
of a strategic move.
Of course, he’s not gonna remove Results
altogether from the platform and stay completely
out of the loop.
But, it’s clear that he would rather continue
to focus on core Instagram products and treat
Reels as an addition to business instead of
as the future of the business.
And given how well Instagram is already doing,
this seems like strategic calcluated choice.
But all of this still leaves the question,
how in the world does Instagram make so much
money off of just pictures?
IDEAL DEMOGRAPHICS:
Clearly, Meta has perfected how to monetize
Instagram’s massive user base, but that’s
not the only thing they’ve perfect.
Meta has also perfected how to take advantage
of high interest rates and monetize their
$61 billion cash reserves with the help of
high yielding treasury bills and bonds.
The same, however, cannot be said about everyday
people who are still stuck using traditional
bond brokerages that are stuck in the 1970s.
We still have use clunky bond tables, scroll
through long overwhleming lists, and even
use virtual keyboards just to buy bonds.
And that’s why we created our own modern
bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience
and the ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust, so that you too
can easily lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety.
Every Silo account is insured by $500,000
in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
insurnace.
Also, all funds deposited on the platform
is maintained by our trusted custodian, Interactive
Brokers, who has experience managing $373
billion worth of assets over the past 45 years.
So, if you’re looking for a modern way to
invest in bonds, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below.
But anyway, to understand how Instagram became
so lucrative, we have to take a look back
at it’s roots which take us back 2009 to
a young man named Kevin Systrom.
Kevin was your classic high achieving tech
bro.
The man started off by attending Stanford
where he majored in management science and
engineering before turning around and interning
at Odeo which is what would eventually turn
into Twitter before finally getting a job
at Google.
So, Kevin was truly an elite bro, so I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that the
idea for instagram actually came rather naturally
during a vacation.
It turns out that his girlfriend didn’t
want to post vacation pictures on social media
because she felt that the pictures weren’t
high enough quality.
Kevin’s solution to this was to just throw
on a few filters and this is what would lead
to the idea of Instagram, though it was originally
called Burbn.
From there, it didn’t take long for Kevin
to put together a prototype for Burbn and
pitch it to a few VCs at a local party.
They would agree to fund him with $500,000
allowing him to quit his job and go all in
on Burbn.
Initially though, it seems that Kevin was
actually all over the place.
He wanted the app to do as much as possible
from checking into hotels to earning points
for attending social events.
It wasn’t until one of his college friends,
Mike Krieger, joined that company that their
vision became a lot more focused.
Mike was adamant that people did not want
a complicated app and that simplicity was
key.
And as such, the duo would decide to hone
in on just photo sharing and make that as
polished as possible.
And eventually on October 6, 2010, Instagram
would be launched on the app store.
Within the first day itself, Instagram would
rack up 25,000 users.
By the end of the first week, this turned
into 100,000 users.
And by mid december, this turned into 1 million
users.
One of the main reasons for this explosive
growth was Instagram’s crystal clear focus
which translated into a crystal clear demographic
which is the first reason that Instagram is
so lucrative.
Their demographic is not only crystal clear,
it’s also highly monetizable.
Just think about it, what type of person is
most likely to use Instagram?
With YouTube, it’s basically everyone as
YouTube serves all sorts of content from comedy
and gaming to education and finance.
At first glance, it seems that Instagram also
serves all sort of content but when we take
a step back and look at the overarching picture,
one adjective comes to mind: aspirational.
More times than not, people don’t go onto
instagram to look at something truly funny
or entertaining or eduative like they might
with YouTube.
They go on Instagram to look at things that
they don’t have whether it’s the perfect
body or the perfect relationship or the perfect
vacation or the perfect wealth.
And the fact that people only post highly
doctored curated versions of themselves only
plays into this phenomena.
This is why Instagram is commonly cited as
the worst social media for mental health.
But, while that sucks for users of the platform,
it’s perfect for the platform itself as
this creates the perfect breeding ground for
advertisers to play into users’ insecurities
and dreams and maximize on conversation rates.
When you combine this with the resources and
influence of Facebook, well, all of this gets
put into overdrive.
THE FACEBOOK EFFECT:
Facebook got involved with Instagram pretty
early on, just 18 months after launch in fact
in April of 2012.
Facebook would buy out the entire company
for just $1 billion which at the time seemed
like a massive amount, but Zuckerberg clearly
knew what he was doing.
After the acquisition, Kevin was for the most
part allowed to run Instagram as an independent
business that simply had access to the resources
of Facebook which was extremely powerful.
Instagram had the agility and speed of a small
startup but also the resources and backing
of a social media giant.
And Kevin would make good use of this by venturing
into the world of copying.
There’s really no easy way to put this.
With the help of Facebook, Instagram would
just go around and blatantly rip off features
from the competition.
The most blatant examples of this are of course
stories, IGTV, and Reels but there are dozens
of smaller examples.
Usually, there’s no point in suing when
it comes to tech because even if you somehow
win the court case, the infringer will probably
come out on top anyway.
If Instagram was a startup, maybe the competition
would have atleast tried, but since they were
now part of Facebook, no one even bothered
giving Instagram free reign to experiment
with whatever feature they wanted.
Instagram was never adamant about any one
of theses features though.
They always had the approach of let’s see
how users respond and how this affects the
business overall and then make a decision.
Pulling back on Reels is just the latest example
of this.
Just two years ago, they completely scrapped
the idea of long form content through IGTV
because according to themselves, users just
weren’t using it.
This freedom to experiment with anything and
everything with little repercussions and consequences
gave Instagram the opportunity to really find
the most successful and lucrative features
and double down on them.
But, that only tells half the story as Facebook
brought something even more important to Instagram:
advertisers.
Before Facebook got involved, Instagram didn’t
even have advertising.
In fact, it’s not clear if Instagram made
any revenue at all, but Facebook would change
this.
In November of 2013, Instagram would show
off their first sponsored post: an ad from
Michael Kors.
Users weren’t too happy with this ad but
Michael Kors was.
In fact, within just the first 18 hours, Michael
Kors would gain 34,000 new followers.
Instagram ads are obviously nowhere near as
effective today as users have gotten used
to them but compared to other platforms, Instagram
is still miles ahead.
The average cost per ad click on Instagram
comes in at $3.56 which is even higher than
YouTube which comes in at $3.21.
This is especially surprising given that on
YouTube, ads usually come in the format of
unskippable videos.
On Instagram, you can easily scroll past any
ad.
So, you would think that getting clicks on
YouTube would be more expensive.
But, it’s actually more expensive on Instagram
largely because of their demographics and
context.
It’s easier to sell a product to someone
who wants to be something that they’re not
as opposed to someone who just wants to get
to the video already.
The only social network that has a higher
cost per click that Instagram is LinkedIn
but that’s a wholenother beast.
Between the freedom to experiment and opportunity
to leverage first in class advertising, it
seemed like Kevin’s partnership with Zuckerberg
was going quite well but this honeymoon phase
didn’t last forever.
NO NEED TO SHARE:
As Instagram started doing better and better
and even started outshining Facebook itself,
the company started having some serious internal
politics.
The Instagram team felt that Facebook got
a steal with the acquisiton and that they
were the future of Facebook.
Meanwhile, the Facebook team felt that that
only reason that Instagram was so successful
was because of Facebook’s backing.
And as you would guess, this drama went all
the way to the top to Mark Zuckerberg and
Kevin Systrom.
Eventually, it got to the point that Zuckerberg
just wanted Kevin and Mike to leave so that
he could take the reigns of both Facebook
and Instagram and reunite the companies.
Zuckerberg didn’t want to flat out fire
these guys though, so instead, he would just
start cutting resources and implementing changes
that would piss them off.
For example, when Kevin was on paternity leave,
Zuckerberg would implement location tracking
and hamburger menus into the app, two features
that Kevin was strongly against.
Eventually, Zuckerberg would come out on top
and both Kevin and Mike would leave, But,
being the undisputed king of both Instagram
and Facebook wasn’t the only place that
Zuckerberg didn’t have to share.
One major advantage that we have yet to discuss
is that Instagram doesn’t have to share
any of their revenue with their creators largely
because their creators aren’t after cash
directly.
More times than not, the main goal of Instagram
users whether it’s the popular kid in high
school or some massive celebrity is to boost
popularity and stay relevant as opposed to
making money.
Of course, money is part of it but with Instagram,
it’s more of something that follows as opposed
to something that leads.
As such, the fact that Instagram doesn’t
share revenue with their creators isn’t
something that really turns away creators.
Of course, there are some exceptions to this
and Instagram does pay creators under certain
circumstances, but it comes to main feed,
Instagram gets to keep all the revenue which
obviously makes a massive difference.
YouTube shares basically half of all their
revenue with creators meaning that the total
revenue that YouTube pulls in is not $30 billion
but actually closer to $60 billion or higher
than Instagram as you would expect.
So, why is Instagram so lucrative?
Well, they have a unique aspirational demographic
that’s perfect for advertising.
They’ve been able to experiment with every
format under the sun to find the most lucrative
and successful formats.
And, historically, they haven’t had to share
much revenue with creators.
When you combine all of this, you end up with
over $50 billion in annual revenue.
Meta as a whole pulls in $126 billion in annual
revenue and they’re worth just over $800
billion.
So, if we were to translate this ratio over
to Instagram, it would mean that Instagram
is worth over $300 billion by themselves.
And that’s why Instagram is the real winner
when it comes to short form content.
They’re not staying out of the loop by ditching
Reels altogether, but they’re also not willing
to cannablize their main business in order
to make Reels work.
With historically high interest rates, the
appeal bills and bonds is the higher than
ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t
really adapted with the times.
They still expect people to use clunky bond
tables, scroll through long overwhleming lists,
and even use virtual keyboards till recently.
And that’s why we created our own modern
bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience
and the ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust, so that you too
can lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety.
Every Silo account is insured by $500,000
in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
insurance.
Also, all funds deposited on the platform
will be maintained by our trusted custodian,
Interactive Brokers, who has experience managing
$373 billion worth of assets over the past
45 years.
So, if you’re looking for a modern way to
invest in bonds, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below.
It doesn’t seem like YouTube got this memo
because that’s precisely what they’ve
been doing.
Check out this video to learn more.